In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for October 8th, on which we commemorate, Saint Pelaia,
the Virgin, Saint Pelaia lived at Antioch in the third century.
She was of noble birth and of great beauty, which she complemented by striving for beauty
of soul.
The governor of the city learned that she was a Christian and sent a detachment of soldiers
to arrest her.
They surrounded the house and were prepared to take her by force if she tried to resist.
But the young woman came out calmly and asked them to allow her a few moments to get ready.
From the example of those who preceded her on the road to martyrdom, she knew that the
ruffians would try to violate the virginity she had consecrated to the Lord.
She made her way to the place in the house where she was accustomed to pray.
Turning towards the east, with hands raised to heaven, and her face streaming with tears,
she spent some little while praying God to spare her this defilement, that she might
depart heavenward with soul and body unstained.
The Lord heard her prayer and assured her conscience that it was preferable to seek
death voluntarily than with body defiled to die under torture.
And so, with heaven sent assurance, she threw herself down from the top of her house and
allowed her soul to take flight towards the dwelling place of the angels and saints.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.